So what is Unreal Engine?
The best way to start thinking about this is that everything starts with you.
Inside of Unreal we have something called a U project, which is the project that you
will load to create your Unreal Engine project.
In Unreal Engine's content browser we have assets that are named U assets and essentially
anything that starts with U is centralized from Unreal Engine.
So in Unreal Engine we create projects.
This will house any of your interactive cinematic animation driven experiences.
We create projects from these files so that you can access all the individual information
within these projects.
Unreal Engine is also made up of editors, tools and systems.
So whether it be an animation editor or a cinematic editor, maybe you're trying to
do some real time lighting information.
Essentially we're using multiple different types of inbuilt tools and editors to create
these projects from.
It also manages assets and logic so Unreal Engine can house the raw data that you bring
in from external packages and creates U asset from it and that's what we'll use to build
our projects with.
And when we refer to logic we're referring to the visual scripting language and also
the C++ language.
We also can plug extra additional functionality into the engine via a plugin.
So there's many different plugins already supported and you can also code your own plugins,
which we'll talk about in a few slides as well.
Unreal Engine can also package and executable and essentially packaging and executable will
take your project, it'll wrap it up into a file that doesn't require the end user to
have Unreal Engine installed and instead they can load the experience or project, whatever
you've created from an executable.
So when we say Unreal Engine we're not thinking about a car engine in that respect.
It's more like a car assembly line.
It's multiple facets to Unreal Engine throughout the development process that can be used.
So it's not an all-in-one closed system as it were.
It's more like a continuous assembly line.
So the main questions we get around when starting with Unreal Engine, what is the difference
between the project editor versus the engine?
So the engine holds all the systems and tools.
It processes the information that's sent to it behind the scenes and it's indirectly
used.
The engine is the under the hood stuff that you don't necessarily need to interface with.
The editor exposes all this powerful functionality.
It visualizes the systems, sub editors and tools to the user.
It allows for asset creation and manipulation.
So when we refer to importing your raw assets into Unreal Engine, whether they be video
files, CAD files, any other 3D asset types, it could be music, it could be a whole host
of assets.
But you can also create assets directly from Unreal Engine as well.
And it sends information from the project to the engine.
So the project is housing all of your important information that you have for the project
and the engine is presenting that project's information.
And the editor is directly used.
So you will be interfacing with the editor when using Unreal Engine.
So when we talk about projects versus a U project, the project is the self-contained
unit of files.
So whenever you open the editor through the launcher, which we'll be talking about again
in a few slides time, the project will house all of this different information.
So when you install it to your hard drive, you'll see a config folder, a content folder,
which we'll talk about and it includes all the bits that the engine really needs to work.
The U project, however, you'll see at the bottom of this slide, which is the blue icon
on the bottom left hand side, is a specific executable.
It's what you'll use to launch the project and it references all the files within this
folder.
So if you think about the example project here as the launcher for the project, it tells
Unreal Engine what content you want to load.
The actual project folder contains all the actual information that you need to have inside
that project.
And as we referred to before, everything starts with U. So U asset is just an Unreal Engine
readable file extension.
It's as straightforward as that.
It's any item that you find within the engine, whether you've imported a static mesh, like
you can see in this example, maybe it's been an audio file or a texture, any kind of imported
objects get turned into U assets.
And things that you've made in Unreal, for example, materials, blueprints, any kind of
particle systems, they all become U assets as well.
So most things in the content browser, unless there's some uncompressed raw file, we've
got very few exceptions inside the Unreal Engine.
So more likely than not, you'll see everything coming through as a U asset.
Moving on to the engine launcher.
As promised, we can choose an engine version from the launcher.
So when you first load Unreal Engine, especially when you're wanting to select Unreal Engine
5, multiple different engine versions to choose from, more often than not, you want to pick
the latest engine version that if you're working on a commercial project, you probably want
to use the latest stable engine, not the early access version of the engine.
You have choice over what engine you do install.
And it's also worth noting that everyone on the project should be using the same version
of the engine as well to prevent any conflicts of information or data.
Once you pick an engine version to use, you should stick with that unless everyone updates.
And then when you choose to install the engine, it will give you a series of options, whether
you want to install some additional content, some C++ content, you've got options to kind
of configure your Unreal Engine install there.
Unreal Engine via P4V is the source built version of the engine.
And we follow some internal guides here.
It does require approval from Unreal Engine and it has got global protect on there.
So if you are using Unreal Engine via P4V and instead of via the launcher, you would
expect to see the additional folders here.
And when we're putting our projects on Perforce, when we're storing the projects, all the green
files should be added to the depot.
The green files highlighted here, so you've got the config, content, source, you project,
and then just a preview of the projects image.
Those files all want to add into your repository because everyone can then build the project
based on those files.
The build, derived data cache, intermediate and saved, they're all temporary files that
can be local to that individual's computer.
So the binaries folder is optional.
It's a large file.
Some people want to upload that for posterity to share along the team.
You don't have to do this all the time.
You may find instances where you choose to do that, but the main folders that you do
want to put on Perforce are highlighted in green here.